In my case it's a little bit different
because I think, probably, my parenting experience
associated with my work experience
becomes probably one of the leading elements
of my life.
Trying to balance a job that is very demanding
in terms of intensive traveling
and having a family and a home
that is also very demanding
with some little comments
coming from a seven-year-old daughter
are often something that makes me think
if I'm always doing the right things,
if I'm getting the right balance
between the effort I'm putting in my job,
which I'm very passionate about,
and a family that I love very much.
But in the end, what is the right place
and where am I making excuses
to try to make the most out of the other side?
So, it's always an interesting subject,
something that is very challenging.
And every time I hear one of my fellows here
talking about the subject,
I'm very intrigued
because I try to get ideas
on how they are coping with a subject
that is probably a big and important one
for many of us,
especially as you move up in positions
that give you a lot of responsibilities,
but with responsibilities,
you also get this,
let's say, downside.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.